[Music]
roman jordan contains an incredible
array of diverse climbs and environments
from the sprawling urban center of roman
philadelphia and the culminated streets
of jerash
to the desert settings of fortifications
on the confines of the empire that were
perpetuated beyond the romans
and we can discover extensive roman
trade routes through the dramatic way of
life in wadi rum
let's explore the expanse of roman
jordan
from up here on the citadel jebel alcala
almost 2 800 feet above sea level you
can get an amazing perspective of amman
the capital of jordan
today's modern skyline of 4 million
inhabitants began its story over ten
thousand years ago in the neolithic age
later the ammonites founded their
capital in 1200 bce calling it rabath
aman
by the third century bce the city
thrived as a new urban center the
ptolemaic philadelphia that finally fell
under the sway of the nabataeans then
rome
it flourished as part of a partially
autonomous confederation of ten cities
called the decapolis formed in 63 bce
and lasting more than two centuries
afterwards it was a byzantine possession
then conquered by the arabs in the 7th
century who renamed it aman harkening
back to its ammonite past it was
contested throughout the middle ages and
ultimately abandoned until the early
20th century
but it was in the roman phase that the
city enjoyed a truly privileged position
in this region of the empire displaying
wealth and prestige throughout the city
i'm archaeologist daria zarya and
together
we'll explore the expanse of the roman
empire over three continents meeting
oversized personalities seeing
incredible monuments in urbanization and
also how rome co-opted and organized the
provinces and their resources
rome left an indelible mark on diverse
cultures that we can still explore today
for insights into the impact and legacy
of the roman empire and how we can
connect to that rich past
it's an adventure
with endless new perspectives to
[Music]
discover in this episode we'll explore
jordan
along the roman empire's dramatic
eastern frontier
[Music]
from the citadel an easily defensible
area with a dominating view you can
enjoy a palimpsest of a byzantine church
an 8th century umayyad palace
and 12th century ayubid watchtower
layers of history
amman was founded on seven hills or
jevos
but the city is so much larger today
look down below us and all around us
this massive urban sprawl
what a spectacular view from the citadel
the city's acropolis
it's already used as a fortified point
in the bronze age but what dominates
your experience today
is the remains of this roman era temple
resting on a podium half the size of a
football field the columns were
re-erected at a height of 45 feet
composed of drums weighing 11 tons of
peace
and it would have been visible to the
people down below in the roman forum
it represents the time of the apogee of
rome
over jordan in the second century ce
[Music]
in fact it's this dedicatory inscription
written in greek
by the dedicator guineas marcianas who
was the provincial governor of arabia
petraea when roman philadelphia was at
its peak
and his career exemplifies the expanse
of the roman empire
he's born in sierta modern algeria goes
to rome as a first generation senator a
novus omo or new man and has his career
in various offices during the cursus
enorm
he is a distinguished general under
marcus aurelius fighting in the parthian
wars
and ends up his career as provincial
governor here
and ultimately afterward
in the province of asia which is the
roman term for western turkey
his offering of this temple mirrors the
pinnacle of roman influence in roman
jordan
the importance of roman citizenship here
the economic and political weight of
rome was dominant throughout this region
but nothing lasts forever and this
temple ultimately falls into ruin to be
reutilized in later constructions in
subsequent periods
indeed the citadel continue to have an
important role afterward first as a
christian center with a byzantine church
and then the sprawling extensive um
palace of the eighth century now the
umea dynasty ruled from 661 to 750 and
it extended its reach from persia
through the middle east across north
africa and into spain one of the
greatest and largest empires in history
[Music]
today the citadel is a key tourist
destination from which you can orient
yourself to a mod's rich history down
below but what's more exciting is to
descend and explore this lively city
[Music]
amidst the busy streets signs of
modernity and socializing in the
bustling capital city where the average
age of its citizens is under 24 years
old
i'm making my way not just to the
historic center of the city with the
grand husseini mosque of 1932
but also the ancient center of ancient
philadelphia
where a portion of the roman era
monuments are still nestled within the
lively urban fabric
[Music]
i'm in the heart of ancient philadelphia
of the second century ce but there
already was an impressive hellenistic
center but under the romans the
prosperity really took off it all
started with pompey the great who
conquered syria and the levant
in 63 bc and as a result this city
always along the caravan route passing
from north to south down to the raven
peninsula
truly benefited
and you have this impressive important
stop on that caravan route in this
magnificent city
the remains today are still impressive
like this greek theater built on a
hillside
and that's in contrast to roman style
theaters that were typically
freestanding
now the skane franz the stage jet right
here is beautifully preserved
this is built in the reign of antonius
pius a period of relative tranquility
and peace in the empire it held 6000
spectators and is still in use today
[Music]
the call to prayer in the heart of
historic oman
this is also the site of the forum of
ancient philadelphia
and it was 100 meters by 50 meters lined
with columns a lot of those columns are
still standing
and this is a place today for strolling
and socializing in antiquity it was the
hub
of politicking and commerce
[Music]
[Music]
i'm in the odeon
which is a music hall just off the forum
looks like a theater
but it's smaller that's because this was
designed for musical performances
singing
debates
lectures
originally there was a wooden roof on
top
and it was all about acoustics
and intimacy it held about 500 people
it's largely intact still today
[Music]
[Music]
ancient philadelphia boasted the assets
of a rich urbanized community with
impressive public venues
and just around the corner there's the
historic mosque of modern oman
so you have this center used in
antiquity and continued to be reused
still today
[Music]
around the corner from the grand
husseini mosque down the street from the
forum is this gigantic nympham or public
fountain
originally the niches were filled with
statuary line with colonnades even
mosaics and a big pool in front
celebrating the largest of this wealthy
city always multicultural and imagine
that experience two thousand years ago
it would have been fantastic in this dry
arid climate
[Music]
philadelphia in ancient imperial times
was largely a semitic culture but with
deep greek roots
in the roman times you add in a level of
wealth and sophistication herbal renewal
and big public monuments
now most of the scriptures that we find
here are in greek
but it's a different world on the street
you'd hear aramaic nabatae and arabic a
mixture of cultures and traditions
and of course we'd find those mixture of
cultures and traditions
also in the kitchen
[Music]
wow
[Music]
what should we have first actually we
got a monster a manta yes
and something is calling magloba
mansoff is one of the quintessential
meals served in jordan
created by local bedouins
and it has a distinct flavor that's
fermented in salty
using jameed which is a fermented
buttermilk which can be from sheep
goat cow even camel
and this
is soaked into the tender lamb's flavor
further enhanced with the baharat spice
blend
with cardamom
and cumin
served on a bed of rice
with a crunch of nuts
delicious
[Music]
is a typical dish
served throughout the levant
and it consists of meat rice and fried
vegetables
placed in a pot
which is flipped upside down when served
hence the name magluba which literally
translates as upside down
this is absolutely amazing and what
makes it so incredible is that you feel
that this is made in someone's home
at the same time
the richness of the flavors is enhanced
by the spices
and we think about the spices in this
region for thousands of years those
caravan routes the nabateans that
tradition
it's still present here and you're going
to have unique tastes and flavors that
you won't have anywhere else
these dishes
speak of the traditions in jordan here
we're in a restaurant that's been around
for 50 years in the historic district of
amman and it's hard to get a sense of
that depth of history unless we go to
some of the ancient cities and i want to
take you now to one of the best
preserved ancient cities in the region
that underlines the depth of history and
the wealth that was obtained also from
the spices we're going to jerash
[Music]
we're headed north just 30 miles to
explore one of the greatest preserved
urban centers from roman times
jerash
known as the pompeii of the middle east
like amman it was also part of the
necopolis that flourished under rome
these ten cities were similar in
language religion and their ties to
hellenistic culture
although the lists of the ten cities
vary they include cities in today's
israel syria and jordan in particular
gerash scaliapolis
hippos
gadara pella philadelphia capitolius
kanawat rafana and damascus
[Music]
most of the cities were greek
foundations created in the third to
second centuries bce
and remain contested by various kingdoms
like the ptolemies the seleucids
nabataeans and judeans then sorted and
organized as a special autonomous
grouping under poppy the great in 63 bce
the cities culturally became a mix of
hellenistic greek jewish nabataean
aramaian and roman
achieving great wealth from their
natural resources namely fertile land
varieties of produce availability of
water and location
along the principal caravan land routes
carrying precious commodities from the
arabian peninsula and the far east
collection and distribution centers of
the goods included taxes levied on
passing caravans goods textiles ivory
frankincense myrrh bitumen dried goods
slaves and more
the decapolis wealth continued to expand
when new road networks were added under
trajan after the area became part of the
new province arabia petraeus
in 106 ce
[Music]
this magnificent arch heavily restored
welcomes you to the outer limits of
jerash
it was constructed
to honor the emperor hadrian in 129 130
when he was actually here
hadrian the restless emperor we spent so
much of his reign
in the provinces not in rome
he was listening
defending improving the empire he
actually wintered here between 129 and
130
and this arch is evocative of the
grandeur of the triumphal arches in rome
the arch of titus and the arches of
temius severus
[Music]
but this is not triumphal over a
vanquished foe but merely to
conspicuously acknowledge the presence
of hadrian on his sojourn
ostensibly the greek inscription records
that it's from the people of cherish
noting that the celebrations of
hadrian's visit and the arch were
financed by a certain flavius agrippa
his name flavius implies that his
family's citizenship occurred under the
flavian emperors
and ultimately this arch celebrates the
wealth of the city but also its
allegiance to rome
[Music]
inhabited as early as the neolithic era
jerash was settled by alexander the
great's veterans then refounded in the
2nd century bce as antioch on the
cursorus the golden river
laid out on a series of terraces the
western side developed according to the
lay of the land with public structures
from north to south parallel with the
river that ran through the middle of the
town
joined by two bridges possibly four the
flatter eastern side developed into a
quarter for large baths and possibly
more residential living
a large circuit of walls over 2.5 miles
long built between the 1st and 3rd
century ce eventually surrounded the
city's 200 acres
but its disparate parts became unified
by colonnades and piazzas a series of
arches and monumental fountains that
leave the visitors spellbound today
[Music]
a huge area outside the city walls lined
with tombs was cleared out for the
construction of this circus for chariot
racing and you have here some of the
best preserved carcides or starting
blocks in the ancient world
[Music]
this held up to 15 000 spectators and
some of the seating is still preserved
actually considered to be the smallest
circus from the ancient world just about
265 meters long consider that the circus
maximus is over 600 meters long
nevertheless
having a hippodrome or circus is a sign
of wealth and prominence of the city
and a rarity in the greek east
now this was constructed by about 220 ce
it doesn't last very long there seems to
be some structural problems
so it goes out of use pretty early but
in the northern end
a wall is inserted and you have then an
amphitheater for gladiatorial
competitions in other portions of the
circus it's converted into an industrial
center particularly for the production
of ceramics and that lasts into the
byzantine period
[Music]
past tombs shops and even a byzantine
era church we finally come to the
massive wall circuit at the monumental
southern gate
passing through it we arrive in one of
the most marvelously conceived urban
spaces in the roman world
[Music]
i'm at the oval forum of jerash this is
an amazing architectural space and
you're surrounded still today by the
original columns this is a space created
to connect you to all parts of the city
it accommodates you as you come through
the city gates it can direct you in an
oblique angle up to the grand sanctuary
of zeus and the major theater and it
introduces you to the beginning of the
cardo this main elegant avenue that
conducts you to the rest of the city
got the pavement here that's original
you've got a masterful creation a
wonderful architectural space and it
really does give you a grand sense of
how amazing this city once was
[Music]
the roman era sanctuary of zeus this
grand temple
overlooks the opal forum it greets you
as you enter the city it's a kind of an
acropolis-like setting right next to the
magnificent theater
it is one of the two key sanctuaries in
the city of jerash
[Music]
when you walked through ancient imperial
rome you had a stunning display of
colonnades everywhere lining porticos
carrying you through the campus marshes
the roman forum the imperial four all
the way to the coliseum but we've lost
that we have it here in jairish
countless columns still standing on the
main street the cardo stretches on today
still
750 meters it's an incredible experience
and it's intersected by two main roads
two decomani the southern one
connects to the cardo with a nice round
piazza highlighted by four individual
tetrapylon structures
and further north the other decommanas
you have a large quadruphon's arch
spanning the cardo
so you have an incredible array of
architecture
and of course besides the colonnades
here the street was lined with shops
offices
a large nymphaean fountain
and even a mccallum it was an
extraordinary experience and antiquity
[Music]
[Music]
the sanctuary of the city patron artemis
was constructed later in the ensenade
period
it was a masterpiece of planning and one
of the largest sanctuaries in the roman
world
it too was terrorist
responding to the natural topography of
the city
with a huge staircase and its colonnaded
promenade
with trapezoidal courtyard extended
across the river to the eastern side of
the city the central piazza was a
whopping 161 by 121 meters
and the experience today is stunning as
all of the fundamental architectural
pieces remain in place
entertainment in the ancient world was a
way to show off your wealth
it was a way to amuse the public
you're showing religious piety
and everyone
is able to participate and enjoy
so in the southern part of the city you
have a large classical theater which is
for mimes pantomimes acrobats comedies
here in the north we have the music hall
or the odeon
to each of the city there are two large
public bath complexes in the byzantine
era there were three more added
hosting games
was on the part of the city or wealthy
individuals for example we have flavius
garenes in the time of trajan he's
offering to trajan athletic competitions
in honor of the emperor the emperor who
had just financed a lot of rebuilding of
the city after an earthquake in 113.
[Music]
the city would have been familiar to any
roman of the second century you had all
those components of a grand roman city
this is the mccallum a place for selling
fish and meat
so what you have is a city that benefits
from the wealth attained from trade and
commerce
you have
investment from the city you have
imperial patronage particularly from the
flavin era all the way through the
antonines
[Music]
[Music]
in the christian era the city went
through radical transformation
and you have that moment of recycling
and repurposing so much architecture
big blocks into new constructions there
are documented 20 churches and three
byzantine bath complexes
and some of them were quite large like
this cathedral it's gigantic
in the shadow of the temple of artemis
and that's not by chance
[Music]
[Music]
we're here in a space in the shadow of
the temple of artemis and you have a big
saw that's powered by this water wheel
what a great use of the water to power
have this technology
in place at a time when you need to
recycle the material it's very effective
it's very efficient it's very
industrialized and right here we can see
the cuts made by the saw this particular
block of marble is abandoned but we can
see the precision with the blades and
how many blades are actually used so
it's a great example of what existed
also in antiquity so rarely preserved
here we have it in the byzantine era
when life was still thriving in jerash
[Music]
jerash is destabilized and even overrun
by the persian sassanids in the early
7th century
by the mid 7th century it's now muslim
and you have your first mosque then you
have the destructive forces of a massive
earthquake in the middle of the 8th
century and the city never recovers it's
pretty much shrinking down to a small
village
by about the 12th century there's even a
crusader fort but then it's entirely
abandoned and becomes a quarry site
fast forward to the excavations and the
rediscovery of jerash in the early 20th
century
but they've just begun to scratch the
surface because the eastern half of this
ancient city is still underneath modern
jerash today
[Music]
we're driving down the king's highway
known in the roman period as the via
regia it was the principal land route
that the nabataean-led caravans took
from the red sea in the south heading
north to syria laden with goods
frankincense mirror batuman ivory
destined for the grand roman market
the emperor trajan organized the area
into a new roman province arabia
petraeus
and built a new main road the via triana
nova
nevatian's primacy shrank under the wave
of new roads new routes and ultimately a
new line of defense
the fortified limase eravacus which
lasted for centuries
[Music]
afterward in the byzantine period the
king's road became an important
christian pilgrimage route for nearby
mount nabo
moses's death and burial site and under
muslim control in the 7th century it was
a new pilgrimage route the hajj from
syria to mecca
finally the road was superseded by the
ottomans tariq al-bint route in the 16th
century
followed by the early 20th century
hajja's railway line
[Music]
this fortress the casa vasir was part of
the limes arabicus
defended against arab raids and
protected the territory from brigands it
was always a porous border with control
over strategic locations
we're 50 miles south of amman an arid
stepland at an elevation of 800 meters
the fort is strategically located with a
view to the north over a river valley
one and a half miles away
and half a mile away is a ridge
overlooking the desert to the east
it's perfect for cavalry patrols
this small fort was intended for half of
the normal limitani troops
those men stationed along the border
so just 60 men total and their mounts
this fort is famous for its level of
preservation
an inscription over the gateway dates it
to the diocletianic era around 293 to
306 ce
the structure is rather small
roughly square
56 by 57 meters
it displays the typical architecture of
this time for a castellum
projecting towers at the corners and
flanking the gate
an inner courtyard surrounded on all
four sides by barracks and stables
[Music]
after the bottle of yarmouk not far away
that ended the roman rule of the middle
east in 636
many others created new circuits of
castles along this line
defensive and for communication but have
a different more imposing nature
[Music]
the crusader king baldwin the first
built this fortification after the first
crusade in 1115.
it's known as crocte montreal and mons
regales because the king himself was
associated with its construction
its purpose was twofold
one was to protect the eastern frontier
of the kingdom of jerusalem and the
other was to control the critical
corridor from egypt to syria
the castle was located in a
quintessential strategic location as
fertile planes surrounded an isolated
hilltop
essentially it was impregnable and not
far off there was petra
that so long ago controlled the same
land corridor for trade and commerce
[Music]
in 1187 the ayah bid sultan saladin
attacked jerusalem and it fell
immediately then he came here because
this was such a strategic location
brought his siege engines he thought it
would be over very quickly but instead
this castle resisted how is it possible
for two years
they had a secret
they had previously dug a tunnel
375 steps piercing through the entire
height of this hill to hit water a
natural spring so they're able to resist
but ultimately it fell
in 1189 ending the presence of the
crusaders in transjordan
[Music]
the ayamid dynasty doesn't use this
fortification for too long because
there's a dramatic earthquake in 1211.
we fast forward to the 13th century and
the mamluk dynasty is now in charge of
this region they're going to build over
the crusader fort and they're going to
build something much more dramatic
much more lasting
but in the early 16th century the
ottomans take over
and they decide to neglect and
essentially abandon this structure and
that's why we find it in this condition
today
control and protection define these
castles but that's not the entire story
in this region let's continue south to
explore a different facet of ancient
jordan
in the desert where the nomadic city
life is preserved still today
[Music]
there's nothing in the world like wadi
rum
and one of the reasons is because
you have this unique sand
full of iron oxide that makes it
this red color
and for this reason
wadi rum stands in for off world for
mars for dunes arrakis and the desert
planets of star wars and it really does
deserve to have that kind of feel of
being in another world because there's
nothing with this beautiful landscape
there's nothing like this on the planet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
wadi ram is known by the locals as wadi
al-kamar that's valley of the moon
this is a world heritage site
that's consists of 285 square miles
granite formations weathered sandstone
canyons
valleys
natural arches red sand deserts
it's forever associated with t.e
lawrence who was here and wrote about
his impressions during the arab revolt
from 1917 to 1918.
the massive formation behind me is known
to the locals
as hashem al-masmar
but to tourists and people around the
world
it's known as the seven pillars of
wisdom
[Music]
[Music]
25 000 petroglyphs are etched in the
walls
of the canyons of wadi rum 20 000
inscriptions in nabatean the mudic and
arabic
documenting the lives of people in
pastoral societies
and traders and caravans there's so much
history here in wadi rum
there's 154 archaeological sites one
notable nabataean temple
we have been documented
12 000 years of occupation of this space
and so many of the inscriptions are
navitan in their period of flourishing
from the 2nd century bc through the 1st
century ce
[Music]
[Music]
kept on
life of the bedouin in the villages in
wadi rum
is linked to the ancient past and that
way of life
and also linked with tourism today
animal husbandry of goats
and of drominaries that is the arabian
camel
hearty beasts that can really endure
this harsh terrain that activity lives
on
and what you have is in the mix
excursions to the desert
into the mountains
this terrain is harsh
and formed a way of life that was
minimalist
you have freezing nights boiling hot
days
and still today that life of the bedouin
is tied to those traditions
there's no urbanization here
the dramatic life is part of their dna
always
around this striking
beautiful setting
[Music]
we've seen that the rich varied history
of jordan is literally written on the
walls
recording the caravan routes matched by
this otherworldly landscape
before and after the romans people have
tried to dominate the harsh land of
jordan with caravan highways mighty
urban centers desert fortifications and
more
today
exploring the natural landscape of wadi
rum once part of the expansive roman
empire
we can contemplate just how much this
corner of that world was always an
entity unto itself
still waiting to be discovered to
connect to its ancient past
[Music]
you